dix mille scouts de france se réunissent
aujourd'hui à la plaine de la chan dans
le puy de dôme ce rassemblement prévu de
longue date intervient une semaine après
le drame qui a coûté la vie à deux
adolescents en mayenne au coeur des
préoccupations la sécurité et
l'encadrement
reportage anne charline lambard et
jean-jacques le deuil est ce que c'est
la bâche et pour le village cet accord
durant quatre jours fille libre ans
qu'on s'apprête à gérer une ville de
dhimmis coûte une agglomération avec
tribune canalisations d'eau groupe
électrogène une ville complète sorti de
terre en quelques jours aujourd'hui plus
qu'auparavant il se dit plus vigilants
lors du contrôle des installations au
cours de ses tournées il répète
inlassablement les consignes de sécurité
même moment on met tous des façons pour
évoquer donc l acier
après après vous allez prendre soin de
vous lâcher ses autres qui vont se
prendre à rêver
vous en prenez deux pour les t2 à
l'intérieur on prenait 2 chacun nous
avons d'une part nos services internes
qui vérifie que toutes les installations
sont faites suivant les normes qu'on a
pu établir ou qu'on la lui donner au
départ ensuite on a des bureaux de
contrôle professionnels qui viennent
vérifier toutes les installations et
ensuite on a une contre une commission
de sécurité pilotée par la préfecture
qui vient contrôler l'ensemble des fils
pour croire effectivement validé
l'ouverture de restaurants vont arriver
derrière christelle et olivier encadre
un groupe de loire atlantique
à eux deux ils surveillent huit jeunes
alors que le ministère de la jeunesse et
des sports exige un encadrant pour 12
personnes titulaires de qualification à
gré bafa ils déplorent la multiplication
des règles même s'ils gardent en tête
l'incident de perros guirec et celui de
la semaine dernière
je pense que ça peut démotiver certain
qu'ils pourraient vouloir se lancer dans
l'encadrement
je pense que pour les jeunes oui ça
enlève un petit quelque chose qui avait
en le scoutisme ya encore quelques
années - d'aventuré moins de plaisir le
scoutisme doit compter avec les règles
de sécurité
deux ans après laffaire de l'abbé
cottard les effectifs des 8-12 ans
continue de baisser